new trailer footage has released with
doctor strange and a multiverse of
madness and there's a ton of new footage
so let's break it down it starts off
with the eye of agmoto and then cuts the
shot of doctor strange carefully walking
upstairs he's looking very cautious here
and it looks like he doesn't know what
to expect so he's taking his time and
he's being careful this looks to be a
part of the same sequence where we see
this mysterious door open leading up to
a staircase just because of the color
grading in that they share a similar
looking environment as we can tell from
the water in both scenes moving on we
have a shot of doctor strange in the
sanctum sanctorum and then it cuts to
some very exciting shots here we have
this ribbon looking monster chasing
america chavez and defender strange it
looks like they're in trouble here and i
would say this is either just before or
after the sequence of america chavez
being captured by this creature we then
have a ton of new footage from the
temple scene where they are attacked by
this mysterious person now as i've said
in previous videos i believe this
mysterious person is wonder because if
we splash together some footage it just
works too well and looks like one is
attacking them with the new footage here
we have a shot of doctor strange and
wong looking at this incoming smoke and
their new shots of doctor sharings and
wong they look worried and not sure what
to do and anticipating what their next
move is also if you're looking in the
background here you can see people
preparing they're in a defensive stance
they're ready to attack and then just a
quick new shot of doctor strange wong in
america chavez next up we have new
footage of wong who is seen struggling
he's in this mysterious mountain
location with snow blowing in his face
and he's struggling to climb up this
mountain now if we look at previous
footage of this snow location this is
where we see zombie doctor strange so i
assume wong is going to have an account
with him here we have shots of doctor
strange he is looking very very defeated
here in the second shot here of doctor
strange looking defeated he has been
taken captive here i assume this is from
the scene where america chavez has also
been taken captive because if we look at
this previously released picture it's in
the exact same environment we then have
doctor strange being escorted by ultron
bots now he's being brought in front of
what we assume is professor x and
illuminati then we have two new quick
shots of doctor strange and the america
chavez america chavez is surrounded by
candles here they're mysteriously just
blown out now we've seen similar looking
candles previously with that scene of
wonder meditating so this makes me think
wu america chavez meet wonder in this
scene or are these just completely
different candles at completely
different times let me know what you
think in the comment section below then
we just have two quick extended shots of
mordo attacking doctor strange and
zombie doctor strange in the snow
environment we're talking about the
staircase scene before but yet again
from the same environment we have new
footage doctor strange is looking behind
him possibly he's looking at someone or
something or maybe he's just
reconsidering his decision should i walk
up this set of stairs or should i not
the remaining footage i will break down
i would say is probably the most
exciting from this whole trailer so we
have new footage of wonder here
defending herself against this high
energy attack now i would say this is
from the mysterious person we have seen
previously in the trailers everyone is
thinking this mysterious person is
superior iron man but i believe this
person is actually a variant of captain
marvel next up we have a shot of seems
strange being attacked by this energy
looking spell if you go to the next shot
here we have a show of doctor strange
struggling to contain a spell or
something of some kind so this makes me
wonder is this sincere strange being
attacked by doctor strange or is there
someone else involved such as the
scarlet witch because it does look like
both trying to contain this energy blast
unless if these are from two completely
different scenes next up we probably
have the most sam romy looking scene
from everything we have seen from this
film so far door slams shut as the
camera zooms in and then we cut to our
heroes here as the camera pans closer
towards them now our heroes here all
looking disturbed and confused on what
is going on and finally the last shot
from this trailer we have is of wonder
inside of what looks like is the mirror
dimension so my prediction is that
wander and doctor strange have engaged
in a fight of some kind and doctor
strange has trapped her inside the
mirror dimension and she is trying to
escape it possibly this red energy blast
we see is actually of hers and it's just
reflecting off the surfaces anyway guys
that's it for all the new footage from
this trailer so if you did enjoy this
video please like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching